si tu devais partir sur une sur une île
déserte
tu choisis avec qui entre deux Chavannes
de cônes Frédéric Mitterrand au moins tu
prends avec qui
alors de roter on arrive à un moment
maintenant c'est les fameuses questions
cons
alors ça commence simplement tes
jartelles ou collante bon d'accord tu es
soutiens-gorge ou seins nus tu sais j'ai
pas vraiment toujours trouvé un matériel
est-ce que tu es slip ou quels sont
quelle chouette
des grands
est-ce que tu préfères
si tu si tu dis que
[Rires]
tu préférerais mourir
rayon laser bombe à neutrons ou casino
d'or
au laser ça fait plus spectacle
[Applaudissements]
si tu pouvais continuer à t'en prendre
aux invités
j'imagine que tu sois coincé dans un
ascenseur déjà imagine que tu sois
coincé dans un ascenseur tu préférais
être coincé avec qui
Catherine Lara
se marre pas Muriel Robin
ou Marie-Paule Belle
avec toi dans un ascenseur pendant
combien de temps tu tiendras tu crois
c'est la seule qui reste de patiner
alors ton Jules y arrive pas imagine
c'est une supposition tout ça c'est des
questions
supposition
tu lui demandes comment elle s'appelle
première supposition deuxième
supposition tu lui fais un truc spécial
pour qu'il y aille troisième supposition
tu te casses en claquant la porte
[Rires]
à demain tu te casses en claquant la
porte
la question suivante j'aimerais bien te
la poser
ici quoi pas devant pas devant tout le
monde
voilà pas loin d'accord tu viens OK
si tu devais partir sur une sur une île
déserte
tu choisis avec qui entre deux Chavannes
de Caunes Frédéric Mitterrand au moins
tu prendras qui
je suis obligé de dire toi non
franchement
ne pas être triste
avec moi
on y retourne
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
ça a pas marché mais j'ai une ouverture
c'est où
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
tube abonnez-vous et mettez un pouce
bleu